joining us former deputy governor of the
bank of England that's the John gave
hello to John thanks for joining us
markets like stability is Jeremy Hunt
the man
well I think he started well I I think
what in the background to what he's
saying today is three three things
really his his first job is to give
himself enough space to produce a proper
budget with spending and and how to pay
for it at the end of the month and he
obviously is worried that he has to say
something today in order to give himself
those extra days to work out what's
going to be a very very difficult
package
but the second thing is one of the big
things that's making his job more
difficult is higher interest rates which
are increasing the costs of servicing
the government's debt and are squeezing
the rest of his budget and so by taking
action today
he hopes and expects to reduce interest
rates and thus ease the pressures that
he has to take account of in the
official forecast
how does he do that Mr John does he make
another couple of announcements today
does he talk about another couple of
u-turns from what we heard at the end of
September
well it looks like he's on his way to
talk to you so you can ask him but I um
I I don't know exactly what he's going
to say but I think probably what he's
found when he got to when he got the
forecast the draft forecast is that
there's a bigger hole than he'd expected
and he simply can't afford the rest of
the tax cuts which were included in the
mini budget he'll preserve I'm sure the
energy prize cap and I expect him not to
reverse again the National Insurance
measure which went through Parliament I
think last week so apart from that he
can't afford tax cuts because there's a
bigger hole in his in his finances than
he was expecting and so I'm afraid what
we're now probably going to see at the
end of the month is tax increases as
well as spending cuts
goodness
um can you elaborate on that for me
um right I can't tell you what he's
going to do but I think that um the
underlying apart from the 45 billion of
the mini budget tax cuts I think the
underlying uh outlook for the economy
and for public finances has deteriorated
partly because of higher interest rates
partly because of higher inflation and
partly because the world's
um output is is is declining so all of
those things mean that he his job of
trying to produce a medium-term plan to
to make public finances sustainable is
harder than I think many people thought
it's not just a question of financing
the 25 billion that remains of the mini
budget tax cuts it's um it's also
um filling the the filling a gap which
is a risen in in in the Prospect for
Public Finance is quite independently of
that
for you when the previous Chancellor
I you know it was
um I was as surprised as anyone else I
mean uh
but I think but I think that that was
the background to that that decision
that they realized that they not only if
you like got their announcements in the
wrong order but they didn't have a
credible package that they could put in
place to finance the tax cuts they'd
announced and that
um the U-turn which they hope to be a
small U-turn the corporation tax
measures
changed
was necessary in order to balance the
books and that made his position or it
made the truth is it made
the whole government's position very
difficult and um
uh that that I'm sure is why she took
the decision to dismiss the chancellor
John I don't know if you're gonna ask
I'm going to ask you anyway on breakfast
this Monday morning should is the prime
minister's job safe
well look I I don't know as much as you
do about that obviously you just read
the papers you listen to the news we
listen to you our position isn't safe
you have MPS coming on just before I
arrived saying they're not happy
um I think she of course her position is
is very perilous